president Donald Trump disinvited the
Super Bowl champion Philadelphia Eagles
to visit the White House disinvited them
yeah when Trump found out that most the
team wouldn't be coming so he found that
out and he said yeah well guess what
I disinvite you all right now you may
have noticed this has become an
embarrassment for the president because
there are a lot of athletes that are
refusing to visit our controversial
commander-in-chief this has happened too
many times since from spent president
so as a service for our president we've
put together a list of all the sports
figures who are willing still willing to
visit the White House mr. president get
out your pen here they are this includes
the Arena Football champs the Albany
Empire still willing PB a southwest
regional champion John lemoncello the
kings of cornhole a CEO doubles chance
guy windows in cash McCain Malaysia's
third ranked eSport team did [ __ ]
dynasty Lacombe frisbee golf and beer
volleyball groundskeeper Jonathan Finn's
ugly Moulin Rouge slots champ Meg
Chambliss and of course OJ Simpson
[Applause]
you